how do you greet héctor mejía
informative consumer it is thursday and this
june 16 years is the sentence that
a truck driver received behind bars
after having run over and killed
five cyclists near shorts light in
december torrent version pleaded
guilty for  two day charges
resulting in death
changing the subject the department of
labor released a new report
in this indicates that 376 thousand
americans filed for unemployment
last week for the first time this is the
lowest number so far in the
pandemic but only just slightly
below the number recorded the
previous week raised to another 4,200
applied for benefits this is a
15 percent drop compared to
the previous week
now the vicente stadium will be
hosting a
coronavirus vaccination clinic and it all starts on the
day of  today through sunday and then
again next week appointments
start at 2 pm but you can also
call  egar walk-ins people who get
vaccinated at this site will get a little
surprise gift
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we'll still have some
40 mph valley winds through
maker airport
we'll have a spring afternoon with
temperatures hovering around 80 degrees but
get ready it's because
triple-digit temperatures will return this weekend i
have a nice day i'm héctor mejía
and this was your brief news on
spanish kirchner
[Music]